drop me whenever you want whenever you
feel something is not clear we can make
it as interactive as as possible so I'm
going to talk about night pipe and
analyzing brain imaging data and I'm
sure many of you are curious about
what's going on inside heads of other
people maybe it's your boss maybe it's
your spouse well I'm curious what's
inside of my head when I'm trying to
make lame jokes so the problem with
figuring that out is it's how to keep
the specimen intact when you try to peek
into what's going on inside the head and
so basically in vivo or in other words
keeping the subject alive imaging and we
have these wonderful machines for over
30 years now which are called the
magnetic resonance scanners and they
work using quantum physics to peek
inside a tissue it was originally
developed for looking into material
design and faults and different
structures and metals but then was
adopted to have higher spatial accuracy
and literally produce images like this
that without slicing any brains allows
you to see how a particular part of our
body looks like and we're going to focus
on the human brain and in brain imaging
there are multiple different data types
and the most common one is focus on
structure and this is what you see here
and structural MRI scale so called
t1-weighted scan and shows you different
folds of the brain you can infer
actually the surface of the folding of
the brain from it and you can divide
into different sub regions you can try
to look at features such as the
thickness of the cortex because the the
brain cells the neurons and they have
their cell bodies on the outside of the
brain and connects through axons through
the inside of the brain so the layer
outside of the brain is where the cell
bodies are
and that layer can have different
thickness in different people and that
could be an indication on certain
diseases or capabilities etc etc this is
one type of data that we're dealing with
another one is functional MRI so the
previous being was fairly static was
very slow like we had a brain and maybe
your the the cortical folding or
actually cortical thickness will change
from now till when you gonna be older by
10 years so maybe when you're gonna
learn a very intense skill but it's very
slow process changes that we see there
are very very slow but we can use a
different type of scan that is
susceptible to blood flow and this is
another fascinating story when a lot of
different things had to come together
for this to actually happen basically
someone figure out that oxygenated and
deoxygenated blood have different
magnetic properties and using magnetic
resonance we can pick on that that
wouldn't be enough if it wasn't for the
wonderful vascular system of our brains
which actually has a built-in
optimization in it so basically if I am
using one part of the brain and it has
higher power consumption so it requires
more metabolites to recover there is an
increased blood flow but not too
everywhere but only to the part that
actually requires more energy and
because of that combined with the fact
that oxygenated and deoxygenated blood
have different magnetic properties we
are actually able to localize which
parts of the brain are active during
particular tasks so we put people in the
scanner and we tell them to do a thing
and then in contrast that thing with
doing a different thing and this way we
can figure out which part of the brain
was more involved between block ay and
Block B simplest thing I can put the
subject into the scanner
the person to tap their finger for let's
say 20 seconds and then do nothing for
20 seconds tap their finger don't tap
their finger and contrast those two and
I will see the motor cortex which is
responsible for our movements and
consuming more energy through the proxy
of the blood flow and and this requires
us to acquire many different images of
the brain one after another and a
sequence that's not all we also have
something called diffusion MRI and this
type of data allows us to look at the
structure of the connections of the
brain so remember when I talked about
the the cortical folding the layer
outside and the connections going
through the brain those are the
connections those are the accents and
another fascinating physical phenomenon
that allows us to do that is that we can
have a specific scan with a specific
directionality that probes Brownian
movement of water molecules in a
particular one direction so Brownian
movement is basically atoms moving
around when they are not in absolute
zero and so whatever that for example
glass of water gentlemen is pouring
their molecules inside that glass of
water will move around by themselves but
if you put them into a straw that straw
will restrict the movement in one axis
but not the other axis and accents
because of their fatty coils around them
basically look like straws so if you can
figure out which direction the movement
is restricted to we can figure out where
the accents are and this is what
diffusion imaging does and we can get
those beautiful images out of this
showing us where those tubes are
basically bundles consisting of many
many different accents are and which
parts of the brain they connect and
again here we have to acquire many
different images of the brain to probe
different directions
the same time okay so as you can see
this platter of different data that we
can get out of the human brain to use
for stabbing healthy as well as disease
populations predict outcomes or or try
to understand how the health plan works
but we're here to talk about data and
the beautiful thing about scanners is
that they have a fairly standardized
ways of outputting data and most of it
is daikon which is a medical form quite
rich in metadata but unfortunately the
standardization is is not as great
because different manufacturers will add
or remove certain bits this is a nifty
file format which is more more more used
in the academic community but what you
really have to know about this data is
that it's basically a three-dimensional
cube a three-dimensional numpy array
basically to speak the the Python
language and sometimes there's a fourth
dimension when you have multiple stacks
of the same volume as I mentioned with
the functional scans or the diffusion
sense but what do we want to do with
this data what where is the challenge
what kind of things we can do and want
to do with this first of all we need to
do some cleaning the scanner doesn't
give a give us images that are perfectly
clean and there are some deformations
for example here we have a deformation
and the orbitofrontal areas which is
caused by the fact that there is air and
the sinuses and which changes the
magnetic field which causes this
distortion this brain doesn't look we
don't have horns in our brains like on
the image on the left but because of
that air there is a distortion and
because of individual differences the
amount of air will be different and
different person people will have
different distortions but we have waste
for correcting that is an extra data and
particular algorithms
there's also motion correction people
move in this counter because well we
cannot stay still all the time and even
those micro movements I'm talking about
the limited
basically a slight rotation can cause
spurious results so we also want to
correct for that and we also have
methods for that basically you can do
special chord restriction of individual
volumes and time and then there's also
physiological noise I started my career
doing neurosurgery's or helping doing
your surgery so I'm not a real doctor so
there needs help
don't look at me so and the thing that
struck me the most is when you open the
skull you can see the brain pulsating
and why is that because it because of
the blood flow so there is a physical
movement caused by by how blood flow
influences the cerebrospinal fluid in
the brain and that movement and those
confounds can also disrupt our results
so we can also deal with that through
various and denoising methods but the
nice thing is not all we also want to do
some kind of a normalization we rarely
study a single individual person we want
to we want to make our conclusions based
on groups we want to generalize to other
people so we need to acquire data from
many different subjects and then the
question is how do we put all of those
results in the same space and and here
the problem is basically of taking all
of those brains which are obtained the
discounts were obtained in different
orientations and putting them into
basically the same space and the other
problem is that people are people brains
are different they have different
foldings and you want to not only rotate
them and maybe change their sizes scale
them but also do some nonlinear
transformation to those brains to make
them look similar to be able to localize
changes more accurately and finally
there is teacher extraction when we get
our brains moist and we got them
normalized into the same space now we
want to figure out what kind of features
we want to extract on we're going to get
a signal
we talked about cortical thickness
that's one of the signals you can
extract is the asking how the thickness
of the cortex changes with regards to
whatever we are studying for example
between people who are experiencing or
suffering from Parkinson's and normal
controls but there are many many other
features that we can also extract we can
talk about connectivity I've talked a
little bit about diffusion scanning and
tracing accents in the brain that would
be structural connectivity but they can
also look at this in more kind of
information theory point of view when
you have time courses in different parts
of the brain and you would look how
similar they are and basically try to
infer whether there is shared
information between parts of the brain
based on their temple or information and
that would be a hint that there is
something ongoing between them and that
can be basically a connection and then
finally they could be also tasks related
both signals so when I mentioned that
finger tapping and your contrasting
people finger tapping versus the same
people not finger tapping this is
basically nothing else than fitting a
very simple GLM model to the time series
in every single part of the brain
independently and trying to figure out
which parts of those of the brain are
tracking our design and here our design
is very simple either I move the finger
or not and that gives us localization
there are many many many other features
that people try to extract from the
brain so what I'm talking about all this
where is the Python where is the data
and basically all of this has been done
or helped people have been researching
the solution methods and dealing with
MRI for over 25 years now and there has
been tons of different software written
for it but it has been written mostly in
academic environment so I don't know
who's who's here has been working with
with software written
by scientists right so unless unless
those are the the the software carpentry
trained scientists you can expect a
certain flavor yes thank you thank you
certain flavor there's some diversity
it's quite a terminus this is this is
the best illustration who came up with
it's basically explosion of color and
let me give you some examples of that
and so this is a one of the toolboxes
that that we are using in the field is
the most popular way of analyzing
functional MRI it's right now 15 years
old or something like that ins written
in matlab which is great of course and
and it has this user interface which is
this MATLAB --is-- UI it allows you to
do scripting by writing m-files that
basically write the sort of a badge code
when you send jobs and tell what what
the input arguments are etc etc but this
piece of sauce was written by the most
cited neuroscientists in history among
and many others people and there's a lot
of expertise in it well let's give you
another example so this is a command
line for one of the best preju stration
methods in the field and as you can see
it's very flavorful
what's that spicy spicy yeah very dense
so so what will be the best thing to do
is this port everything to Python right
right right right right no
so well it's all about the money isn't
it
so basically writing complex code is
expensive so if we were to take all
these methods and we write them into
Python and actually keep doing that
while researchers come up with new
methods that would be incredibly tall
order and that would be very very
expensive but that's not all
testing complex code is even harder so
we're talking about methods with our
cutting-edge research practices and
people are arguing what is the best way
of validating these things there are
really hard questions about what is
really the ground truth in many of these
methods writing unit tests for this is a
nightmare and many of the pieces of
software that we are using maintain
their quality by having a big user base
so basically in other words we have many
many researchers using that software
when they see something funky because
they do inspect the results they bring
it up and they basically are an army of
testers which is also very expensive to
replicate so what we're gonna do tonight
pipe to the rescue so now pipe is
nothing else the framework that tries to
unify the way you access all of these
tools so instead of reinventing the
wheel we're trying to make it easier for
you to take those tools as building
blocks and build your apps build your
platforms as well as in our case build
workflows so what we're gonna do when I
do this big data processing thing when
you do the noising and then you do the
normalization and they need to feature
extraction and connect this into that
big workflow and you wanna pick and
choose from different packages different
sources of software written maybe in
MATLAB maybe written in Python maybe
written in C and compiled but I want to
be able to combine all of them in one
framework so this is what an IDE
and at its core in nine five you have
the concept of an interface and
interface is nothing else than a Python
wrapper around the particular piece of
software this is an interface for
something that this scary named brain
extraction tool it doesn't actually
physically extract any brains from it so
no people were harm and writing this
software it basically tries to from the
image remove this cowl and remove
everything that is not the brain which
helps later on with card destruction and
and here I'll just declare this as an
instance of an object I'll fill in the
inputs and I just call the run method
and this one is a common line tool
written in C and I can do the same for a
different interface and and this one
does the alignment which is basically
motion correction so you have many many
different volumes and you want to
correct them so they would all be
aligned together and as you can see it's
the same scheme instance of an object
set input and then call run but under
the hood what my pipe will do will
create this incredibly flavorful M file
and and run MATLAB or actually compiled
version of MATLAB if that is available
so you wouldn't have to have a license
and at the end you don't have to deal
with all of this because what you are
dealing with with is this likable
pythonic code and the reason why this
whole idea because we've been running
nitride for a few years now is so
successful is that we try to make
writing those wrappers very very simple
so to write a wrapper you have to define
three classes you have to define the
inputs and the outputs and the decor
meet of the of the
of your of your rapper so to streamline
this process we are heavily based on
object-oriented programming so we
inherit a lot of things so you don't
have to repeat your code over and over
again so for example here this is a
command-line interface so you're gonna
inherit a lot from a command-line class
which will do the command-line things
for you
this is separate one for MATLAB etc etc
and the other thing we were using our
traits who knows traits traits okay
types
typing strong typing okay Python typing
now yes so so traits actually brings
back typing - to Python and that is
helpful and this is those are basically
the traits object that is helpful
because now we can validate the inputs
that people provide to the interfaces
before we even run them so that's an
extra layer of of error checking so for
example if you expect the file and you
give us a number we like dude was wrong
and and then we're not gonna even run it
and okay so and the other thing is that
for them here is a command line
interface so to translate this
particular input to part of the command
line the string that you're actually
gonna execute this arc string which is
nothing else than like Python or C style
string replacement nothing and this
could have flags this could be a
positional argument etc etcetera
etcetera we've got it all covered and
then this is the main meat of the of the
interface as you can see there's a
command line inheritance you set up the
inputs you tell which which actual
command is it and this would be a little
bit different for matlab things and with
different for purely pythonic things so
because it is so easy to write those
interfaces our community grew very fast
and is very very vibrant right now and
by being allowing people to make small
but meaningful
traditions to your projects that do not
require learning a large chunk of the
codebase you are attracting more and
more contributors so we have plenty of
new PRS coming from places I never heard
of and right now we have over a hundred
contributors which makes me very very
happy for a relatively niche project
when you think about it and I believe
this is not scientifically tested
obviously but I believe this is because
making those small contributions is so
easy a lot of those PRS are not major
refactorings or adding major new
features those are basically new
interfaces or correction for all the
interfaces so if you can inject that
into your projects you can benefit
greatly okay so we have the interface
this part okay that's so off like we
have those unified ways of calling
things what we can do with this well you
can start using them directly to build
your apps tools platforms or you can
actually build workflows and work those
is what we are more interested in and
here's a disclaimer I am fully aware
there are many different workflow
engines out there and some of them are
brilliant and great and this is yet
another one and we've been working on it
for a while and I personally would like
to switch to something else they will
have to maintain all this code but there
are some features that are unique to
ours that people got used to and it's
hard to replicate somewhere else not
less let me explain what it does so
basically it has some standard features
such as caching for example by run a
workflow and then I try to run it again
it will just bring the outputs from
cache if I change something in the
middle of the workflow from one of the
inputs and and I try to run again it
will bring everything up to that point
from the cache and only we run the
things that are necessary to do run we
can also iterate over parameters it's
going to show in a bit we can have sub
workflows and because of fun out in
front and back
basically a branching pattern so we
consider the map note a lot of these
tools they operate on a single file but
you want to run a list of files we have
that covered and basically switch
something from a node to a map node
which is a standard MapReduce thing you
map you run everything on individual
files and then you reduce it to a list
of results
those have iterables commonly in this
kind of scenarios you want to iterate
over a set of parameters you have some
kind of denoising scheme for example
there's the the a our models are
commonly used here as well for temporal
the noising and you want to check some
parameters you want to iterate over them
but you want to see the the for example
the output at the very end how does it
relate to this changes in the very
beginning so this is how you can do it
easily when you basically specify what
input you want to iterate over and what
are the variables you want to use for
the iteration and that will split the
workflow into sub trees
you can also join them together at the
very end if you want to merge something
into a group level analysis on something
like that so if all these nice features
and the other thing that is also quite
interesting is that we support execution
on different systems different
schedulers and high performance
computers and basically this is very
easy it's nothing else than doing
workload run and specifying which
plug-in you want to use depending on
what scheduler is used in your cluster
or you can run it locally on a multi
processor computer etc etcetera so I
presume and some of you might be
wondering high performance computers
clusters like what about I thought a
peas are dead
duuude are you from the past but what
about the infinite clouds and what's the
meaning of life so so
yes that might be surprising to some
people especially coming to the field
from outside not to academia but
high-performance computers or
supercomputers or clusters basically
multi-tenant system for for doing
processing are very common in academia
still and I don't think that's going to
change and let me explain why it's
because there are still cheaper if you
can keep your far more computers your
own Hardware busy at all times it is
still cheaper than renting stuff from
Amazon especially if that system could
be shared across users so that's why it
is a multi-tenant system so many of
these high-performance computers do not
give you root access on your virtual
machine you basically are your user and
you're sharing notes with other users
and there's various policies there are
priorities there are accused etcetera
etc but within this within those
constraints this is still cheaper
nonetheless you can still always spin
your own cluster in the cloud and so
basically rent your own cluster from
Amazon or Google or or something else
and there's a nifty piece of software
called star cluster that allows you to
do that quite easily and on top of that
night pipe also supports AWS s3 so you
can always pull and push to s3 if you
wish to do that well double be all from
me I hope that with this little
introduction I explain a little bit
about the different types of data we're
dealing in your imaging and surely the
knight pipe is a useful tool for
creating your own data processing
services our medical apps but also good
for writing your own workflows and
pipelines if you want to learn more go
to Knight
org slash knight pipe and I want to
thank all of my collaborators as you
probably noticed there are no names in
this presentation
including mine because this is not only
my project this is project of everyone
who's contributing to it and this is a
big community and everyone should be
credited for the effort thank you very
much yes
yes excellent question let me repeat
that Parenthood here at the question was
well we're using HPC spot using all
these different software aren't we
dependent on the capability of
individual packages to run in an HPC
environment so the answer to that is
that most of the paralyzation that gets
you the farthest and is is trivial
because you paralyze over subjects you
paralyze over completely independent
tasks and you can run basically
processes that are completely
independent in parallel and they do not
require support for MPI or any other
sophisticated technologies and that
really gets you far it's true most of
these pieces of sorter do not support
technologies like MPI some of them do
support multi-threading and you can take
advantage of that when you basically you
know send them to a beefy node and let
it know that it has 16 CPUs to to use
but as I said you can get really far
with just trivial parallelization over
subjects or individual tasks
night pipe party
yes
so it is mostly academic but there are
some companies that are using it kind of
in the back to provide data processing
as a service you don't always hear much
from them it's it's hard to kind of
figure out how many companies actually
do that the the project is licensed with
Apache 2 license II can literally do
whatever you want with it and we're
encouraging people from the industry to
take advantage of this and hopefully
maybe like give something back in terms
of PRS and yep
all right so this is a great question
and for I just hear containers in the
air for some reason so basically the
question was what about all the
dependencies you have to have the
software installed and that's a burden
what about like the obscure dependencies
like a MATLAB license server and things
like that so for a long time there was
no good solution for this because
virtual machines had an overhead docker
containers had the ridiculous
requirements that kind of kernel
versions and they're they're unusable in
H pcs but this has very recently changed
with very lightweight containers that do
not do any user mapping do not do any
network management or strong sandboxing
they've just deal with capturing
dependencies and those containers are
called singularity and you can convert
docker to singularity and it all works
so we are looking Marmol to this
technology and we are it's fairly new
they're only a handful of clusters out
there that use it but that will be the
solution basically to capture all of
these dependencies it will not deal with
the MATLAB license thing but there's
another workaround it's called the
MATLAB compiled version or much compiled
runtime allows any MATLAB programmer to
take their thing what they wrote and
compile it into a portable product that
they can send for anyone to run without
the license and this is how we are using
a lot of this software
okay yeah great question an individual
personal Diagnostics require a lot of
distributions basically so if we want to
figure out how you personally you know
your particular cortical folding etc etc
is predicted of many different things we
need to collect a lot of data from other
people so I think not enough of that is
being done and an iPod is not able to
solve that problem because it's data
collection problem we need to have these
those distributions but there are
projects out there that are doing a
great job for example is the UK biobank
who which started recently and their
goal is to scan a normal distribution of
a hundred thousand people and the idea
is that you scan hundred thousand people
now and there are they're actually
targeting people that are slightly older
and then they follow up and you know
five percent of them will develop
dementia and because they've got the the
time point in the past they can design
predictive methods to figure out who's
gonna get dementia in the future but
because it's such a big data set you can
get those distributions for for example
you can have a distribution specific for
gender specific age ranges and other
things and we can use those specific
distributions to take a new subject a
new patient and and figure out what is
the best way of treating that particular
person which points to the precision
medicine but those coefficient methods
are very important because you have to
bring people together anyway because we
have to interpret you in the context of
a distribution which is specific to you
but still a distribution pulling from
more people
yep
yes so right right now yeah right now a
lot of the science done with kind of
working or something that everyone now
is wrong that all brains are the same
which is kind of a chicken and egg thing
we want
it's a regularization problem in other
words we want to put brains in roughly
the same space but at the same time we
don't remove the variance that we're
actually looking at or we looking for so
it is a bit of a chicken and egg problem
but but I believe the kind of
individualized distributions are on the
rise and we're gonna see more or more of
that and there are methods to create
templates that are specific for your
study or specific for your population
and I pad the support and some of them
all right oh and don't believe in MRI
lie detectors